all right sandra
sandra where'd you grow up where are you
from originally
i'm from los angeles
and tell me about your family growing up
you had mom and dad
um i didn't i didn't grow up with my dad
my mom
she passed away
um when i was little so i grew up with
my grandma
how was were you when you lost your mom
i was a baby
i didn't well i didn't get to know her
you know so i grew up with my grandma
and i'm only child
and
so it's kind of hard you know being by
yourself
but um
you know my grandma being old and stuff
i was just always alone
um
i had a few friends
but i always kept to myself you know
because
just not having my mom and
being by myself
but um
how would you describe your childhood in
general
um
lonely and i was lonely
um
just because i didn't
have any siblings so and it was just me
my grandma yeah so
you know i didn't really go out or
do much what kind of what kind of girl
were you in high school
um
i was a very shy girl
in high school
in middle school elementary i was
bullied a lot because i wore glasses and
stuff like that
but um
i mean kind of grew up and just got over
it and
like i said i was just
you know lonely
how old are you now right now i'm
i'm about to be 25.
i was yeah i'm gonna be 25. you're right
you graduated high school yes i did and
you when did you first start doing this
kind of work when i what when did you
first start working as a prostitute um
when i was 20
yeah in 2017.
were you
what were your reasons for doing that
just because my grandma passed
and then i ended by myself
so i had nowhere to go and
so do you have kids
no no kids i don't have no kids so you
know it led me to this
and um
i mean it's been hard
but i
i thought it was going to be harder than
it seems to be
but what i learned is that
being a prostitute is not all about
having sex
you'll be surprised what you find out
there
um
what i do is
i found a lot of
men that have fetages
so
that's what i kind of do
you know
it
at first i thought it was just having
sex with men but no
um there's weird people out there
um
i've heard yeah i've had people that
just paid me to have my feet
on their face like or
pee on them or
just
weird things you know not just
sex and you could probably make more
money that way
you do you'll be surprised um
probably probably attract more regular
clients too right yeah you see i've been
doing this for almost five years now
and
i think i've only probably had sex with
maybe three people really
it's
i've
had nothing but people that have weird
fetishes you know and um
that's that's what i do so you don't
you probably won't work figaro street or
will you i do
but how do you attract a guy that is
into a fetish well you see
it's just
you know from one knowing one person
they send out their friends so they go
find me
and um that's that's how that's a word
of mouth spreads and you
yeah so it but
but the
crazy thing about it is that
you have girls that don't don't like you
you know and
they feel like
they feel like they should do what
you're doing just because they've been
there longer because they feel like oh
she's not having sex she's not you know
putting herself at risk but you do you
still put yourself at risk because you
never know what
your intentions are
but
um i thank god that
luckily nothing
bad bad has happened to me
but i mean
it's a lot of weird stuff out there that
is there less shame for you because
you're doing this stuff that
isn't really i guess i guess you could
call it sex but it's almost like it's
not sex it's
yeah i mean putting your feet in this
guy's face is not
yeah i mean
it's gone as far as
having people wanting to
you to poop on them like you know it's
just
it's crazy like
i mean
it's just
how does it affect you emotionally
to be to be
defecating on people or i mean
it's
it's not something that i would want
like my kids to know in the future i
guess you could say
but i mean
it's nothing that i'm ashamed of because
you know it's made me who i am but um
it's just
it made me really
no like i don't know just open my eyes
to like
a whole different world you know because
i would never in my life expected people
to
be into like
women having family fee or i've had men
that came to me and told me next time i
come back make sure your feet smell
so it's like
okay you know like what do i do to have
my feet smell you know it's just it's
crazy so
i mean
it's it's just amazing out there like
what people
like
yeah
do you find you respect men less because
of what you've learned
no
i just
i mean i don't
i don't i see them the same you know
it's just everybody has different
qualities i guess yeah i guess you could
argue that they're not hurting anybody
yeah they're just into what they're into
yeah what do you what what's your theory
on why
some guys or some people are into
these very
unusual
fetishes
um
i'm not sure sometimes i think maybe
because
most of the men that i've
done things for
don't have a mom
so it's like i don't know if it's
because they don't have
that that mother
whether you love or whatever you want to
call it like i don't know or uh
i'm not sure
like i really never asked but
it's just
it's amazing like how
there's certain men that i ran into that
can't go to sleep without having feet in
their face
or
just
that sensation of having a
like
i don't know a foot in their face which
is weird it's funny but it's like
i don't know i would never understand
like what's
behind that you know what i mean yeah i
mean i i would guess it's something in
their childhood but who knows
who knows for certain i don't know
yeah
so you
you you don't have a grandmother anymore
you don't have your mom no your dad was
never in your life no
no i'm by myself oh yeah you're you're
an only child so and you have no
children so there's it's just you yeah
this is me well you have friends
yeah friends i mean
you know i got to
meet a lot of people out here
being in the street um
you know friends come and go
unfortunately
and
i mean
it's
it's hard being out here in the street
because
you know i never thought
you could see a friend and then next
thing you know they're gone
and
i never understood this saying about
people when they would tell me
all your dead homies right
that's that's uh
something they use out in the street
and
being out here now i understand why they
say that because it's like
basically it's like
when they're asking you something and
they
they want to know the truth it's like
they ask you
put it on your dead homies and like i
never thought
anything about it until i finally
started losing friends
being out here
because i've had friends that got raped
got killed
and
you know it's it's sad because it's like
you never see him again
yeah but um
it's just like they say like it's never
good to
be mad at a friend
when they leave or
or just
be in bad terms with anybody period you
know when they leave or sit say bye
because you never know if you're going
to see them or not
and um
i mean it's been hard you know
um
i've been through a lot of drive-bys
um being out here
um
a lot of people trying to you know take
your purse just because you're a female
and they see you as like being weak
or you know
but it
it's basically how you carry yourself
um
i believe if i didn't
carry myself like i do
i wouldn't
i probably wouldn't be here you know
because it's just like
a lot of people tend to feed off of
women that are
like
in fear or
you know or just like
hiding or
you know like with weak women
but um it's like you have to be strong
out here and
i mean if you're not strong trust me the
streets will make you strong
and um
i mean
i wouldn't want
my kids to do this
but um like i said like you know you
never know where life takes you
and um
you know only god knows why things
happen
what do you think what do you think most
people don't understand about girls that
do this kind of work
i mean
i'm pretty sure everybody thinks when
they see you out in the street oh
there's a hooker you know she's a
prostitute she's having sex
but it's not always that
you know like i said it's like
that's what i mean that's what i thought
being out here i thought i'm gonna have
sex with men and
not something that i liked or wanted to
do
but you know
i ended up hearing
like i said
i'm not saying it's good but
at least i'm not
out here
you know just having sex with men i'm
i'm out here like
you know making
making them feel better you know like
you're a therapist of sorts kind of yeah
was there another life that you wanted
for yourself when you were younger you
were still young of course but yeah well
actually i went to school for nursing
but
you know after my grandmother passed
away
um
i i just stopped going to school
and i didn't have no money to pay for my
you know my school so
you know i thought
you know let me make some money yeah to
put that down for a while yeah so but
unfortunately right now i'm still out
here
but that's something that i'm still
waiting to accomplish no i want to be a
registered nurse good for you
are you saving money
yeah you are
and drugs are not a part of your life no
thank god no
i drink
but
drugs no yeah do you have to drink to do
this kind of work
no i don't have to drink but i drink
just because it makes me feel
a little bit more comfortable doing it
and um
just kind of relaxes me i guess you
could say mm-hmm
were there any examples of a loving
relationship in your childhood that you
saw when you were a young girl anyone
any examples of a loving relationship
like you your dad was not in your life
no did you ever see
a man and a woman having her
inside no you see because my grandma was
by herself too because my grandpa passed
away so it was basically like
it was always like just loneliness
you know i didn't see no
i didn't know what it was to be loved
or
having
someone else by your side
or a
significant other you know
so
have you been in love before
um
i actually have a boyfriend
and um
you know he knows he knows what i do
but um
it's
still
it still doesn't feel like
the relationship that
i guess you could say
a normal girl would have you know what i
mean
um
but i mean
he's there for me he supports me
um but
it's just i hope that
in the future we
you know
we just see this as
something that we had to do just to
kind of survive you know for now
is there is there shame on your part
in what you do
no
at first there i was ashamed but then
it's just like i said like
it wouldn't make me who i am now you
know what i mean
and
i'm not ashamed of who i
am is this just uh survival for you
yes you're just trying to make ends meet
for now yeah
was your favorite memory as a child
um
my my favorite memory me and my grandma
and i used to
um
go out to her garden
and she had chicken she had a lot of
chickens
and we used to go every morning get the
eggs
um you know just
she was very
humble she was very
she liked to stay in you know
she would hardly go to the market
like i said chef chicken so we wouldn't
have to order store by eggs
um
but i mean i love my grandma you know i
just
i just wish she was a little bit happier
you know but i know that she was a
lonely lady
and i don't know if that's just
why i'm
yeah i'm the way i am now you know
would you describe yourself as happy
as what would you describe yourself as
happy
i'm happy now
i wasn't in the beginning because i was
lonely i was always only
but
like i said i got to know a lot of
people out here
um you know
i have a boyfriend
and
it's just
it's something different you know
because i know that i have someone i
could go home to
um
someone that's gonna be there for me
and um
[Music]
i know that
i have someone to lay next to you know
not not by myself
do you think you're in some ways
addicted to the fast money that you're
making
it is
you get used to it
but one thing that i've learned is that
you can get
you can't get greedy
because once you get greedy it's just
it becomes an issue out here in the
streets
and it's like you can't
brag about how much you make
or how much you have
because then that causes problems
and
you know that's something you always try
to avoid
do you ever sit back and look at what
you're doing and just think this is this
is a crazy way to be making it
i do money i do because i know there's
better ways
but like i said it was
fast money
what kind of things have you learned in
doing this kind of work that
helped you
along the way
like you're there you have to use your
intuition to figure out who who you can
trust and who you can't
i always go with my instincts um
it's just like if i'm not
fitting that person
or if i feel like
i'm not safe i won't
get in the car with them or i won't
even talk to them i'll just you know
walk away
but
i thank god that i haven't ran into
anybody that
you know hurt me or anything like that
you haven't had that experience i i
would assume that the fetish
community probably isn't as
problematic as the uh
the more
conventional tricks on the on figaro
street yeah those are those are probably
there's probably more drugs in that
crowd than than yours right you guys
just have a fetish they're trying to
yeah satisfy yeah because
i mean
i ran into men you know that just wanted
to have sex and stuff like that that's
the first thing they put out on the
table drugs
and it's like
sometimes i mean
don't get me wrong it i've been tempted
to do it
just because i needed the money
but
you know i
i thank god that i didn't go that route
because i wouldn't know
where i would be now
but um
i mean like i said i don't judge anybody
and
it's like prostitution is not something
everybody could do
and
it's like i told my friend one time i
admire her even though she's a
prostitute i admire her because
i can't i i can't
see myself doing it i don't have the
courage to actually
have sex with men just to have i can't
like i just can't
and
it's like
you know it's
even though it's considered kind of the
same thing but it it's
not in your view it's it's a different
thing you're doing yeah
what's what's the strangest request
you've had
um
it would be
pooping on someone's chest
as they eat a sandwich
as they eat a sandwich
does the guy
feel embarrassed by asking for this or
he just no it's
it's like
it's normal to them and it's
it's i mean i see it as whoa like that's
crazy but
it's like
normal so normal it's crazy like i don't
i don't even
ask why but it's just did you go to a
motel room for this or
yeah for most part yeah we go to
motels but
i've had men that actually
take me to their mother's house
and
like your mom's right next door but they
don't care and it's
it's like
that's when you you realize like
man like you would think
they would have a little bit more
respect because it's their parents
but no like it's just amazing how like
people just really don't care you know
and it's like that's how i know that
or at least i feel like i'm a little bit
more normal because it's like at least i
care like it's like i'm like are you
sure like i don't feel comfortable doing
it here because your parents are here
you know but it's like
i mean when
they're into that they're just into that
it don't matter where it's at where they
do it are a lot of your
clients married you think and they maybe
can't do this stuff with their spouses
you know what i've had
clients
with their wife
and they've had me
do things
as a you know as a couple like
and i'm just like oh i never thought
people
or couples were like this but
like i said you'll be surprised yeah
what is what is this work taught you
about human nature
um it's
it's just crazy
that's all i could say yeah
humans are interesting right mm-hmm
very interesting people out there
what would you say is the most important
thing you've learned in your life
um
no matter what value yourself
um it doesn't matter what you do
always carry yourself
with respect
and
know your worth
[Music]
all right thank you thank you so much
for sharing your story
i wish you the best of luck thank you
thank you
you